嗨 大家好
我是宋晏仁 宋醫師
歡迎來到初日會客室
今天我們特別邀訪的是
陳哲宏 陳博士
還是要請您介紹一下自己
是 宋醫師謝謝你
真的很高興
在臺灣又可以碰到面
臺大畢業以後
我就直接到美國的
UC Berkeley
去那邊唸 PhD
後來以後就到了 Cornell 做學術研究
做完學術研究以後呢
我就回到加州
就在 Stanford 醫學院
就找了一份工作
第 34 年 我在醫學院做研究
今天要跟您談的題目其實是
您在紐約時報
被採訪提到的一個叫做
Asian Glow
我一開始也看到 Asian Glow
聽起來好像是亞洲之光的感覺對不對
其實它還有另外一個意思是
叫做 Asian Flush
就是亞洲人喝了酒之後
臉上會泛出紅光
只有亞洲人喝了酒
臉就會變紅
特別明顯
大家認為說喝酒臉紅是好事情
因為他們認為酒精揮發快
所以我喝酒臉紅代謝快
我的肝功能好
我喝酒臉紅是健康
這是很大很大的迷思
其實臉紅就是乙醛造成
就是你
你已經中毒了
乙醛可能很多人不知道
但是它是真正毒性發生的位置
我現在把它叫做
叫做 Alcohol Intolerance
那它的原理跟乳糖不耐症
非常相像的
也就是我們缺乏一個酵素
乳糖不耐症就是你缺少這個
乳糖代謝這個酵素
酒精不耐症也是一樣
你喝了酒
所以你沒有這個酵素
你就是不耐喝酒
酒精的代謝非常簡單
它就是需要兩個酵素
一個叫做
酒精喝到肚子裡面
很快的用這個酒精去氫酶
把酒精轉化成乙醛
那乙醛需要再靠
第二個很重要的肝的酵素叫做
把它代謝成乙酸
東方人在這兩個酵素
跟西方人是完全不一樣的
我們這個酒精去氫酶
Alcohol Dehydrogenase 代謝非常發達
非常快
比白種人同樣一杯酒喝下去
我們產生乙醛的效率大概是
OK 差這麼大的
差這麼大
臺灣又非常盛行的這個 ALDH2
又有一個基因的單點的突變
把我們這個酵素的功能完全破壞掉了
所以我們大部分的東亞人
像我就是一個典型的臺灣人
我喝下去馬上就產生乙醛
但是我又缺乏這個 ALDH2
乙醛去氫酶這個酵素
所以這怎麼樣
就像一條水管
我們堵在那裡了
而且
跟全世界相比
臺灣人的酒精不耐症問題是很嚴重嗎
患有您剛剛講的酒精不耐症的人
比例大概有多少
比起東亞的比如說 韓國 日本
中國南部
臺灣是不是
更嚴重
這麼高
我可以給大家講一個數字
那日本人比臺灣低一點
大概 40% 也是相當高
韓國大概有 35%
OK
那中國呢
就看地域
南方非常高
北方過了長江以北
酒精不耐症的族群比較少
因為我們過去對基因突變的概念都是
基因突變常常都會造成
不好 傷害
對
所以這個基因會被排除掉
可是這個基因的變異
反而是變成一個某種程度的優勢
是
天擇
把它留下來的
故意把它留下來的
所以這樣子就造成我們東方人
其實反而少酒精成癮症
因此酒精性肝炎
在臺灣相對來講是少的
那我們要怎麼樣知道
自己有酒精不耐症
您說您自己發展出一個工具 對不對
那我們有協會有製作這個
很簡單的一個操作說明
我們這個 DIY 工具打開
一個就是酒精棉片
這個就是我們一般在消毒擦手的
酒精棉片
當然這個酒精濃度非常高
70%
但是事實上你不需要用這個
事實上你用威士忌也可以
你倒紅酒也可以
你就
用一個棉片把它沾濕
然後就貼在你的手背上
所以一般的酒精棉片就可以
對你一般 事實上
買一個 ok 蹦
OK 所以其實這是一個非常簡單的測試
我們小朋友都可以測的
甚至於不需要專門買這個工具
那你現在這個表皮細胞在喝了
大概十分鐘
你如果有酒精不耐症的
它這個乙醛就在這個地方累積了
看看你有沒有紅的一塊
紅紅一塊就是有酒精不耐症
所以我們這個等十分鐘的過程當中
我們繼續來談
就是從科學證據來看
這個酒精的危險性
酒精造成
我們的健康的損害非常大
我們男性十大癌症裡面有
六個癌症都是跟喝酒有關係
口腔癌是我們臺灣男性
第四大最常見的癌症
過去 30 年前一直沒有降下來
男性十大癌症有六個跟酒精有關之外
女性在哪一方面有關呢
女性呢
很重要
乳癌
這個也是民眾
大家不知道的地方
所以就是
加上女性的乳癌
甚至
胰臟癌也有一些關聯
但是沒有那麼強烈
我們現在協會宣導就是
危險因子是什麼
A B C D
我們過去只講 ABC
ABC 是飲食生活習慣
對不對
這個是我們可以選擇的
可以避免的
D 是沒有辦法
菸會致癌
大概比一般人多十倍左右
然後酒精會致癌
比一般人多兩倍左右
加上檳榔
比一般人得到口腔癌的數字是
所以酒精加菸加檳榔很嚴重
那我剛剛
又多了一個 D
多了一個 D 會高到多高呢
我的天哪
每年我們公佈的十大癌症
很多很多都是 ABCD 的人
這裡面可能還有一個
我們叫 compounding factor
因為這幾個癌症
剛好也跟
肥胖有關
然後肥胖臺灣的盛行率
差不多也是 49%
所以
喝酒導致肥胖
喝酒也容易導致肥胖
這也是我們在臨床門診的時候
一看到這個客人來說
他每天都要喝酒
我常常就想說
這就是你的問題
你把這個酒拿掉
肥胖可能就少了很多
特別在我們這個國家
又是一個酒精不耐症的王國
49%的人
喔真的 OK
臺灣人明明不太能夠喝酒
可是我們的酒桌文化
還真的非常發達
其實在早年那個時代
我也感覺比較少人說
我遞了菸 你不拿 人家會說
欸 你抽一根啊
但是你酒拿了不喝
我記得我那時候印象最清楚就是
畢業的謝師宴我遲到了
我老師就是說來
遲到的人先罰三杯
我那天怎麼回家的我完全忘掉
我們的文化一直把
對 所以我覺得這個文化
需要改變
所以這個也是我想做這個衛教
酒精不耐症衛教協會創辦的用意
我也是想說因為這個喝酒文化
確實傷害我們非常非常多人
那政策上面我們對於菸
知道它要防治
所以有菸捐
您會不會贊成也來個酒捐呢
我覺得應該要朝這個方向來做
當然酒捐這個困難度比較高一點
因為涉及一些商業利益 立法
這個問題是比較大
但是我覺得我們是應該
要朝徵收酒捐（口誤）這個方向來講
我想很多政策上的想法
都可以做
WHO 也有很多的建議
倡議 用宣導的方式 要警語
那我想一步一步
我想我們會讓人民會比較健康
這個是我們可以做的
有了菸捐之後
其實現在菸加上
很強大的一個宣傳
告訴你菸害有多麼嚴重
現在臺灣我覺得年輕的一代
吸菸的比例的確比我們這個年代少很多
但是喝酒的文化反而我覺得是比
我們這個年代要嚴重
而且現在年輕人喜歡喝那種混合酒
對
雖然是淡酒一點
但是那個量會無限制
因為它用甜的
我覺得反而是更可怕的一個
掩蓋的方式
從另外一個角度來看
就是我們一般民眾的
一些錯誤認知
常常會給你反駁
我明明覺得酒精喝下去
感覺不錯啊
小酌有益健康
常常聽到有人這麽講
然後我常常其實看到很多老榮民
我跟他說要怎麼樣怎麼樣
他就會講說那宋醫師
我可不可以晚上喝一點小酒
我說為什麼
好睡覺 喝酒助眠
這些觀點到底正不正確
第一 我們要重複 WHO 現在講
所以小酌當然是不好
當然不好
它是隨劑量增加
沒有所謂的閾值
是
只要開始喝就有
喝不多一天一杯
10% 的癌症病人
都是少量飲酒的人
沒有成癮
但是會得到癌症
那我們希望導向當然是
連小酌都不要
精神科的醫師也說
精神科醫師其實也非常強調
你可以睡下去
但是你睡覺的品質不好
好 我們是不是時間到
可以稍微來打開看一下我們這個
今天好像比較沒有紅的感覺
平常我是會很紅的
您好像比較沒有問題
不過還是一樣宋醫師
一級的致癌物
好 我們今天是
非常高興您來帶給我們這麼多
專業的知識
那我們這個節目
會進入一個快問快答的環節
沒有辦法練的
酒量好不好是遺傳的嗎
有一點遺傳
是有一些基因是可以
或是你可以喝很多酒 耐受度
喝酒後臉很紅代表什麼
酒精不耐症
中毒了
坊間賣的解酒藥有沒有用
因為沒有科學的證據
喝酒之後多喝水可以幫助代謝嗎
可以
會加速你的酒精
乙醛從尿裡面排出來
喝酒前先吃點東西墊胃
可以比較不醉嗎
沒有錯
會減緩酒精的吸收
所以你會比較不容易不舒服
為什麼女性的飲酒建議量
會只有男性的一半
兩個原因
第一個
因為女性平均體重比男性低
第二
酒精會影響我們的女性荷爾蒙
所以女性的耐受度比較低
酒的不同種類對身體的傷害有差別嗎
大致上是沒有差別的
大致上
但是有一些添加量可能有的
少幅度的差別
但是酒就是酒
就是有乙醛
跑不掉的
對有飲酒習慣的人來講
您有什麼樣的建議
我們無酒日的口訣就是
5 月 9 日
就是循序漸進
減量
現在有這種戒酒藥物的開發嗎
是有
但是
我覺得你剛剛講的
幾個重點我覺得非常重要
第一個
酒精有 49% 的人是有
不耐症的 臺灣
然後致癌的這個比例
卻被世界衛生組織定義為
一級的致癌物
ABCD 四個字
我覺得是今天的金句
A 就是 Alcohol
B 就是 Betel nut
C 就是 Cigarette
D 就是基因的缺損
那 D 是我們無法決定的
所以臺灣人認命吧
對
做前面三項我們可以做的事情
減少 ABC 的曝露
真的今天非常高興
重逢老朋友
太高興了
謝謝 謝謝宋醫師
40 年之後的重逢
對 很高興